I am with Captain Parker from the LA
County Sheriff's Department we're
standing in front of an awesome car and
this as technology that was integrated
by Raytheon to make the department's job
a lot easier so why don't you walk me
through some of the cooler things inside
this vehicle sure it's you know it's
times have changed a lot my career one
of the things that we now have is the
ability to fingerprint someone in the
field using the blue check device and
that's where it's a small device smaller
than a much smaller than a smartphone
they put the thumb print on it when we
have a legal reason to detain someone
and by putting their thumb onto the
device and we can see their picture and
their identity come through on the
mobile digital computer so there's also
the mapping system so if I have this
right you can see the sister cars in the
same area and get to a location quicker
sure you know in the past it would take
a helicopter overhead to tell us where
were our units deployed as we surrounded
say a neighborhood looking for a burglar
well now with it with the Geo locator
and the tagging that is in the computer
we know where the other units are when
we go in pursuit of a suspect
there-there racing down the street or
the freeway and their lights and siren
and they'll start throwing things after
out the window often they'll throw guns
out the window drugs out the window so
that they don't have it on him when we
stop them we hit a button on the
computer and we did this just a week or
so ago a button on the computer and a
geo tags exactly where the person
through this items out the windows and
instead of a search party looking for it
they find it minutes right fantastic
stuff what is the one feature that you
want to see next from raytheon I think
as far as our system and what we want to
see next is and it is coming down the
line we don't have it yet is that
companies and businesses could
voluntarily give us their IP address and
we would be able to see say in a
convenience store we would be able to
view what's going on on their cameras in
real time inside so that way we don't
have to come into a store with guns
drawn we don't have to walk in blind
what's potentially a robbery or a Miss
just a miscommunication and that's safer
for everybody and scares people less so
you hear that bad guys it's getting much
tougher to be a bad guy in today's my
an environment it's true it's pretty
interesting